please be seated president Bollinger on
behalf of the faculty of the food
foundation School of Engineering and
Applied Science and the class of 2017 I
respectfully ask your permission to
begin these class day exercises thank
you president Bollinger dr. Lee honored
participants distinguished faculty
esteemed alumni I am proud to recognize
the members of the class of 2017 and
mark their shared and individual
accomplishments in these class day
exercises it is now my honor to present
to you the undergraduate senior class
president for the Columbia engineering
class of 2017 cosmas Tim Vindi
[Applause]
Thank You Dean voice I recall vividly
the excitement I felt when I first
learned I'd been admitted into Columbia
I had expected to see my acceptance
decision at midnight which would have
been 5 p.m. Eastern Time however in my
vigil I dodged off I woke up in a panic
at 5:00 the following morning hours
after decision had been released
I barely glanced at my phone the
congratulations was all I needed to know
I screamed a few a shrill scream I
believe I'll never be able to reproduce
that scream served to wake my entire
family they were annoyed at being woken
up yet elated to hear the good news I
was overwhelmed by my happiness and
excitement in that moment I thought I
could truly accomplish anything I put my
size to however as they knew that I'd be
coming to Columbia settled in I began to
wonder if I energy but charged a
teenager from Zimbabwe would be
qualified to succeed among some of the
best minds in the world I was I wondered
if I will be defined solely by my grades
at Columbia I worried if I could keep up
with the rigors of the city that never
sleeps
I know that some of my friends here in
the audience asked themselves the same
questions when I did get to Columbia I
found that my worries and apprehensions
were unfounded in our orientation
programs the activities fair and more I
learned that people at Columbia cared
about more than just Creed they cared
about each other in our first-year
introductory class the edge of
Engineering my fellow Columbia
engineering peers were collaborative in
supportive nothing like the
ultra-competitive
personas I'd imagined after getting
injured four years of training here I
now look back and realize that
even before my arrival at Columbia I
approached things with an engineering
mindset I looked at the situation a
moment of transition and began to look
for possible weaknesses so I could
develop any solution of course this
engineering mindset did not change once
we started classes at Columbia I
remember sitting in my first
contemporary civilization class and
optional parts of the engineering core
we were 20 students drawn around the
world from around the world seated in a
semicircle with our professor and each
table in the center we were discussing
Plato's politics checks I hypothesized
that everyone would have similar
interpretations of the text yet as the
class went on I saw that each of us did
the nuanced interpretation of it if this
assumption was tested and the results
repeated over the rest of the year I
came to appreciate the role people's
backgrounds play in shaping their
perspectives even when I potus's like
the one I ate about fellow students
interpretation is wrong it is the
lessons we learn we receive in such
exercises that we can apply to other
challenges and I the newfound
appreciation for understanding the
context in which a problem exists this
past year I worked with a team of three
other Columbia engineering seniors on a
design on a design project to yoke
improved newborn newborn jaundice
diagnoses in Uganda applying with
lessons taking into consideration the
context of the problem not just
the problem itself one of our teammates
traveled to Uganda to speak with the
very people that would benefit from our
device only through those interactions
in Uganda did we learn the importance of
ensuring that our device was not only
cheap but used in independent portals
every gather today and celebrate our
graduation I apply my engineering
mindset again and all that I've learned
over these past four years
what challenges await us after
graduation when I look at whether we'll
be able to successfully balance work in
life I find the answer in the regular
problem set monthly midterms internship
experiences and campus activities paired
with the accompanying strong and
sustained friendships I see manifested
here today we have already found a way
to balance a full and rich life when I
look at whether I will be able to
interact with new people in new settings
and from different backgrounds I find
the answer in the core of what Columbia
is with the highest international
student percentages amongst the Ivy's
and students drawn from all different
backgrounds there is no doubt in my mind
that we have already been doing this
when I look at what will happen to the
friendships that will build over these
past four years as the clock as the
confines of our campus knows away and
some of us find ourselves in opposite
part of the world if not even out of the
world I wonder will our friendships
weaken yes this could be a problem a
problem unlike anything we've see we've
faced in engineering lingo this is one
problem set with no unforeseen no one
part to maintain our friendships in the
true spirit of our engineering or
engineering disciplines and mindsets let
us use the unique skills and training to
develop these solutions KF one of these
may be a new online platform a new super
fast playing electrical teleportation
may be a new stretch it'd be a new
stretchy bridge the realm of
possibilities is wide open although all
of its to keep us connected for my part
today I challenge us to find ways to
maintain our friendships I admit this is
somewhat selfish because it forces us to
work together over the coming decade
that means we get to stay in touch but
be how is up to you I look forward to
you being part a part of my life and
each other's lives on
many more years to come but for this
moment let us share our celebration
congratulations class of 2017
[Applause]
thank you it is it is now my pleasure to
introduce our keynote speaker dr. Kai
Foley is the chairman and CEO of sign
evasion ventures which was founded in
September of 2009 a leading early stage
investing investment company sign of
recent ventures struggles the next wave
of Chinese high tech companies and sixth
to mentor the next generation of Chinese
entrepreneurs prior to starting sign
evasion ventures dr. Lee was the vice
president of Google and president of
Google China and held the executive
positions at Microsoft's SGI and Apple
in addition to his technology and
investment role dr. Lee is also an
author of six top-selling books two of
which have sold over a million copies
dr. Lee is also active on social
networks with a total of more than 50
million followers he received his
bachelor's degree from Columbia he
received his bachelor's degree from
Columbia University and his PhD from
Carnegie Mellon University nd as an
honor his honorary Doctorate degrees
from the City University of Hong Kong
and Carnegie Mellon University he is the
fellow of the Institute of Agriculture
Onix engineers dr. Lee was the vice
chairman of the committee of hundred in
elite group of Chinese Americans and you
are selected by Time magazine as one of
the hundred most influential people in
the world in 2018 he was appointed in
independent non-executive director of
shangri-la Asia limited in to in
November of 2015 an independent director
of own high precision industry industry
company limited in January of 2016 a
non-executive director of me - Inc in
August of 2016
we're thrilled to have him here with us
today to give the keynote address please
join me in welcoming dr. Cavalli
thank you Kozma and Thank You class of
2017 thank you so much for inviting me
to speak at this wonderful commencement
ceremony it's really an honor to come
back to Colombia to address the
distinguished group of graduates parents
siblings and special guests we've all
gathered here to share the joy of this
day first I want to say to the graduates
I'm so proud of you you did it
[Applause]
your families are proud of you you've
earned this day I remember sitting where
you are 34 years ago feeling that those
were the best years of my life I found
the profession of my life computer
science and artificial intelligence
I found the hobby of my life bridge
I played 30 hours a week but to this day
president Bollinger hasn't given me a
degree in it and I've had my first date
while at Columbia and she became the
love of my life
and finally on my commencement day I got
to sit here sit there and listen to
Isaac Asimov's the famous science
fiction writer and and all you get is me
anyway I had the best years of my life
and that's what you expect me to say and
probably any commencement speaker to say
these are going to the best years of
your life but I'm not going to say that
I know that these are far from the best
days of your lives and I know that your
best days of your lives are yet to come
specifically I hope that the best years
of your lives will be in the next 10
years why 10 years 10 years seems so far
away but really it is not checked him
back with May 2007 might be a good way
to visualize what 10 years can do it's
interesting to remember in 2007 Steve
Jobs introduced the iPhone back then I
was using my blackberry and my wife was
using her Nokia back in 2007 a young
senator named Barack Obama decided to
run for president and
[Applause]
and back in 2007 Donald Trump was still
saying you are fired rather than make
America great again so 10 years did a
lot but the next 10 years will do so so
much more than the last 10 why because
the next decade will be the age of
artificial intelligence or AI as
students you've probably seen AI course
enrollment go from something like 80 to
800 and that certainly is a leading
indicator I was introduced to AI at
Columbia in 1980 as someone who has
worked for 37 years in research
development and investment in AI I can
speak with some authority that AI will
be a revolution that's on the scale of
Industrial Revolution probably larger
and definitely faster but this talk
isn't going to be some hand-wavy AI talk
this is an engineer to engineer talk we
know that AI works we know that AI gets
better with data and more use and we
know how to extrapolate it to measure
its impact in 10 years
so let's first see what AI can do let's
look at three companies I've had the
fortune to invest in the first one is an
AI image processing company that makes
people selfies more beautiful so much so
that no Chinese movie star that I know
would have her photo taken without it
it's user base user size 1.3 billion
people we invested in an AI loan company
that can approve alone in a few seconds
with a default rate much lower than the
human can do in several days this
company is less than 2 years old and
this year is projected to make 30
million loans and that's more than
anything that I am aware of
today we invested in an AI face
recognition company that can recognize
any face from three million faces with
superhuman accuracy if this were
installed in all the airports around the
world with databases of known terrorists
and known wanted criminals they would
never get to enter an airplane these
three AI companies are worth almost 10
billion dollars today but that is loose
change to what compared to what AI can
do in the next 10 years in the next 10
years all financial companies will be
turned upside down with AI replacing
traders bankers accountants research
analysts and insurance agents last year
my personal AI investment algorithm
returned eight times more than my
private banker and that reminds me when
I go home I'm going to fire my private
banker
in the next 10 years a I will replace
most factory workers assistants advisors
and middlemen but AI is not limited to
simple jobs a I will replace many
reporters doctors and yes teachers not
the ones behind me but other teachers
your AI assistant will know better than
you what you want to eat tonight where
you want to go on that next vacation and
whom you want to date and it doesn't
stop there in ten years mechanical AI
will become reliable AI will be able to
drive cars more safely than we do
sweeping changes as it were brought
about by the lowly Roomba sorry well
grow up and cook wash handle all the
household drudgery for us in ten years
because AI will make so much money for
humanity we will enter the age of Plenty
making strides to eradicate poverty and
hunger and giving us all more spare time
and freedom to do what we love but in
ten years because AI will replace about
50% of human jobs we will also enter the
age of confusion and many people will
become depressed as they lose their jobs
and the corresponding self-actualization
and many of you will become parents
concerned about how to improve education
of your children to prevent them from
being replaced by I'm these predictions
are not based on some hand-waving
comparison comparing the number of
neurons in the human brain and the say
eye simulators they are based on an
engineer's extrapolation based on known
algorithms the real marketplace and the
real workforce so in my company we've
raised a billion dollars to invest in
these developments
Softbank has launched a hundred billion
dollar vision fund the tech giants of
the last 50 years
IBM Microsoft Google and Facebook have
all declared themselves to be AI
companies so even if you doubt me you
probably should not doubt all of them
so for leading-edge smart engineers like
yourselves 2027 should be the best times
in your lives unless you miss the AI
revolution in which case it may turn
into the worst times in your lives so so
let me now give you three pieces of
advice how not to miss the age of AI you
might refer to this as the engineering
guide to the artificial intelligence
galaxy so that you can have the best
times in your lives my first advice is
embrace AI and align your career by
betting on is inevitability like all big
change
AI requires you to have an open mind
it's okay to be fearful of change
Mark Twain has said courage is the
resistance to fear mastery of fear not
the absence of fear your hard work has
prepared you to confront or simply
accept or warmly embrace the changes
that AI will bring that will push you in
new directions given what lies ahead
you must warmly embrace AI with while
the first tools of AI in your trade in
your industry might appear fragile be
assured they'll get better with more
data and with use the first the three
software companies I mentioned when they
were originally launched generally make
people uglier not prettier they lost
millions of dollars in bad loans and
when the base recognition looked at me
they thought I was some talk show
celebrity
but given time and more data the self
learning mode of these la I software
made them dramatically better than
people not only are they more accurate
than people they don't get tired they
don't get emotional they don't they
don't go on strike and they're
infinitely scalable so with hardware
software and networking costs coming
down all day I cost is really
electricity so whatever domain you
choose be the first to use the AI tools
if you're going to be a software
engineer use AI tools to check and
optimize your code to help you find
reusable code or even to write some code
for you use your AI tools to find your
team and help you work with your team
and if you start your own software
company use AI tools to manage your
books and maximize your profits use AI
tools to replace your customer support
and your sales people and if you're
going to start a hardware company use
robots to produce your goods and
autonomous vehicles to deliver them the
symbiotic combination of human AI is
really simply explained as one plus one
equals three for example if a doctor can
correctly diagnose cancer and save 70
lives out of 100 and an early AI tool
can save 60 out of 100 perhaps together
they will save 80 and when the AI tool
gets better to save 80 perhaps together
they will save 90 so do not passively
accept AI but embrace AI seek out AI and
find every which way the AI can help you
learn AI and find clever ways to build
that symbiotic relationship early just
like the first reporter who started
using word processing the first
accountant who started using spreadsheet
and the first photographer who started
using Photoshop you would have an edge
in addition AI will evolve much faster
and much more broadly than these tools
your edge will grow and become
sustainable now my second piece of
advice is uphold your responsibilities
as an engineer we all know for centuries
physicians took the Hippocratic oath as
a responsibility to treat human life as
sacred in the Age of AI I think an
engineer's responsibilities are equally
sacred why because as top engineering
graduates from a top school you are the
ones who will write the code for the
future you are the ones with the power
and please remember as my favorite
philosopher spider-man said with great
power comes great responsibility in the
age of AI autonomous and semi autonomous
algorithms will invest money take care
of children drive cars and conduct
surgery you will be the ones building
these products which will impact
people's possession health and even
lives as engineers we cannot abandon our
conscience and sense of responsibility
we need to be thorough diligent and
ethical not just in the archer
architecture and coding but also in the
design the testing how you run your
machine learning algorithms training and
how you download the parameters that are
automatically updated and trained as the
algorithms improved remember when the
first airbags were launched
they saved many lives but they also
accidentally killed some children due to
the lack of adequate design and
instructions that considers consider the
children smaller size so your first
responsibilities are to your users and
to make your product safe thoughtful and
usable and more than product safety you
also have a responsibility to foresee
and prevent potential risks of
Technology so please speak up as experts
not just as engineers when things like
autonomous weapons or bartering and
sales of the privacy data issues
come up your second responsibility is to
yourself in the age of AI you're not
just competing with other people you're
competing with AI you have a
responsibility to yourself to work on
the hard problems and stop wasting time
on what machines will be able to do
don't accept a job that doesn't
challenge you take risks and vigorously
and rigorously learn so that you will
become the best in whatever it is that
you do in something that is very
specific and useful and be creative and
innovative because AI is great at
optimising but AI cannot invent
something new
your final responsibilities is to make
the world a better place with your
choices as an engineer choose jobs that
save lives not destroy them choose jobs
that employ people not demoralize them
work for organizations with more
compassion than greed and work for
people who care more about world peace
than world domination and my last advice
be in touch with your heart based on the
serious text talk earlier this may seem
a little out of place but it really
comes from my heart four years ago I was
diagnosed with fourth stage lymphoma I
faced the real possibility that my
remaining time on this earth was
measured in months during that time of
ultimate uncertainty I thought a lot
about my life I came to realize that all
of my accomplishments and even the
arrival of AI after 30 years of waiting
really meant nothing to me I came to
realize that when I spent my life
chasing technologies products
investments and my careers that my
priorities were out of order I neglected
my family my father had passed away my
mother barely remembered me and my kids
had grown up one of the books I read
during my illness was brawny where's
book
about the regressive people on their
deathbeds she found that no one wish
they had worked harder or spent more
time in the office or accumulated more
possessions people's top wish on their
deathbeds was that they had spent more
time sharing their love with leather
loved ones fortunately I am now in
remission so I am with you today
[Applause]
I'm spending much more time with my
family I moved close to my mother I
travel with my wife
whether on business or for pleasure when
my kids come home I don't take two or
three days off I take two or three weeks
off I also spent more time meaningfully
connecting with more people
I spend weekends traveling with my
friends I took my company on yearly
trips last year we went to Silicon
Valley there Mecca
I met with young people who send me
questions sometimes on Weibo or Facebook
I reached out to people I offended years
ago and apologized to them ask for their
forgiveness and friendship I wrote a
book and shot a documentary to share
what I had learned from my near-death
experience my near-death experience not
only changed my life and my values but
it gave me an enlightened view about
what AI should mean for humanity Elon
Musk and Stephen Hawking has given us
their view a view where machines
supersede humans where we need to
control them or become them with my dear
sorry with my near-death experience I'd
like to offer an alternate ending to
their prediction of the AI future surely
AI has or will beat us are many
analytical tasks with definitive
decisions and outcomes but these tasks
are not what makes us human what makes
us human is that we are able to love the
moment when we see our newborn babies
the feeling of love at first sight the
warm feeling from friends when they
listen to us empathetically the feeling
of self-actualization when we help
someone in need these are all
demonstrate that we're far from
understanding the human heart let alone
replicating it but we do know that
humans are uniquely able to love and be
loved
humans want to be loved and be loved
that loving and being loved is what
makes our lives worthwhile with this
belief we know what we must do at a
minimum
recognize and be thankful that we are
loved we can do better return the love
or maybe return a little more finally
the highest level of love pay it forward
and give love unconditionally coming
back to her ai theme love is what
differentiates us from AI despite what
we saw in some science fiction movies
despite what these movies may portray I
can tell you responsibly that no AI
program of today nor do I think any pro
AI program in the next 10 years or
perhaps in our lifetimes will love they
don't have feelings they don't even have
self consciousness alphago may be the
world champion but it has no fun playing
the game feels no happiness from winning
and certainly has no desire to hug a
loved one after it wins and in the
future even if an AI medical diagnostic
tool is 10 times more accurate than
doctors patients do not want a machines
cold pronouncements such as you have for
stage lymphoma and 70% chance of dying
within 5 years
patients will want a doctor of love a
doctor who listens to our symptoms and
complaints gives us encouragement like
Kye Foley had the same lymphoma and he
survives the you can too
and a doctor of love who is always
available to talk to us and perhaps
perhaps even businesses at home this
kind of doctor of love will not only
make us feel better give us greater
confidence but give us a placebo effect
that will increase our likelihood of
recuperation this will solve the AI
employment problem that 50% I mentioned
because the number of doctors of love
will outnumber today's doctors the
displaced workers can take a take up
career spreading love and their
experiences whether it's a passionate
tour guide and attentive concierge a
funny bartender or infectious sushi chef
with all these new experts of love
titles of many kinds of service jobs
will be created and they don't all have
to be jobs they can be volunteers at an
orphanage or retirement home this will
give people jobs that AI cannot take
away these people will do the job with
pride and a strong sense of
self-actualization
most importantly this will fill a planet
with love and joy we've built many
task-oriented AI that's better than our
brains that was my dream 37 years ago
and as a hard course computer scientist
I'm proud we've come so far but now I
realize that I went after the wrong
organ the most important part of the
human body is not the brain but the
heart that's a lesson that took me I
confess too long to learn my hope is for
all of you as your careers blossom and
your lives take shape that you approach
your lives with all the brains that you
certainly have but also above all with
all the hearts that you can muster
it will be up to you to carry this
forward and I have confidence that if
you let your heart be the guide you will
find your way through the massive
changes that lie ahead and surely make
the next 10 years the best years of your
lives Thank You class of 2017
Thank You dr. Lee in each class there
are men and women who distinguish
themselves and their school through
their superior academic accomplishments
and service to others over the past few
weeks we have recognized undergraduate
students who have been particularly
gracious with their time and talents and
doing so have enhanced the Columbia
community at this time we ask students
who received apartment or athletic
awards were selected as senior marshals
and graduate marshals or were honored at
the leadership and excellence award
ceremony and other celebrations to
please stand to be recognized
[Applause]
thank you for all of your hard work and
we remain grateful for your
contributions to the Columbia community
it's now my pleasure to present the
undergraduate awards given on behalf of
the fou foundation School of Engineering
and Applied Science the George Vincent
Wendel Memorial Award for 2017 is
presented to anthony john pensiero
each department nominates one student
for this honor and from those students
put forth Anthony was selected by vote
of the senior class as the one best
exemplifying the late professor
Wendell's ideals of character
scholarship and service Anthony has a
passion for the infrastructure that
makes modern life possible he served as
president of the Lambda Phi Epsilon
fraternity promoting academic
achievement community service and
leadership on campus and is also
president of the American Society of
Civil Engineers promoting engineering
awareness at Columbia Anthony is also a
member of Camp Kesem Executive Board
working with children of parents with
cancer and runs after-school clubs to
expose students to STEM fields please
help me congratulate Anthony
[Applause]
the designation of salutatorian is a
prestigious academic honor bestowed on
the student who shows the second highest
academic record has superior academic
achievements and reflects leadership
excellence and impact on Columbia
University our salutatorian for the
class of 2017 is Lisa lei Lisa an
electrical engineering major worked on
the first V SLI hybrid computer for her
senior design project and is an avid
traveler who's been to six continents
and 25 countries and continues to add to
that long list after graduation she
plans to enter the ph.d program in
electrical engineering at Stanford
University please help me congratulate
Lisa
[Applause]
the ihling prize the highest honor
awarded to an engineering graduate is
given to our valedictorian the student
with the highest GPA the iliad prize is
awarded by the faculty to know as weavin
for commendable proficiency in his
studies apart from his academic success
noah has traveled to morocco with
engineers Without Borders sung with his
acapella group notes and keys and as a
student leader has camped annually with
co-op the Columbia alder orientation
program before college
Noah spent a year volunteering in Israel
now plans to participate in the venture
for America fellowship a program
connecting recent graduates with
startups
he hopes to pursue a career path that
combines music art and technology please
help me correct congratulate and welcome
to the podium for this year's remarks
the recipient of the Illig prize and
valedictorian for the class of 2017 Noah
[Applause]
[Music]
before I start I just want to say mom
I'm so sorry for forgetting to call
yesterday you're the best I love you and
happy Mother's Day
here we go
I walked into the 3d interfaces lab a
few weeks ago
turn on the hololens a device which
creates hologram and standing in front
of me was a holographic weightlifter
tattooed and shirtless instructing me
how to do squats now I don't workout and
hopefully never will but something about
that moment really stood out to me
computer science linear algebra
electrical engineering and more working
together to produce a lifelike
holographic trainer rippling abs and
doll pumping iron in midair for my first
project in the course the art of
engineering where we sent laser beams
music signals off of solar panels to her
senior design projects I've been
surprised but just how much of an
engineering turned out to be for these
past four years we've been learning how
to bring ideas to life through problem
sets and late night lab sessions wiring
circuits and 3d printing we've been
giving ourselves the tools to transform
the theoretical into an endless array of
creative realities
I watched classmates build stress
monitors for autistic children and
design a robot capable of throwing darts
far more accurately than I ever managed
at 10 20 and well none of these are as
exciting as a holographic shirtless
weightlifter what a powerful thing to
walk up into the world equipped with the
confidence knowledge and skills to take
an idea banging around in your head and
be able to actualize it still early in
my freshman year I call my mom almost in
tears engineering is boring you don't
worry about anything real it's just a
bunch of equations and algorithms and
it's fun and cool as laser music is it's
kind of pointless frustrated with how
esoteric and removed from the real-world
engineering felt I told her maybe I
should switch to the college
thank God didn't go stay with that
later that year I traveled with
engineers Without Borders to Morocco to
build water infrastructure for a
community which had Nam
it was then that engineering clicked for
me engineering wasn't just equipping us
with tools to bring ideas to life it was
empowering us to create things that were
important and impactful using those
esoteric equations and algorithms you
could design a better world sitting in
my American history class learning about
our very own University's involvement in
the Manhattan Project or FM radio it's
clear that the technologies we can and
will create have a profound impact on
the people communities and environments
around us and it's this ability to
affect change and the motivation to
think critically about this impact that
I thank Colombia for the most you don't
go to a school with a community as aware
and engaged as this one without being
pushed to think deeply about the context
and effect of the technology your
engineering last year in the computer
science department a professor issued an
assignment which had students use
machine learning to determine who should
be subjected to stop and frisk and
students push back they argued against
using our creative capabilities to
reinforce a discriminatory and harmful
policing practice without feds and
petitions students demanded that we as
engineers don't just have a
responsibility to create but to create
good so as you go forward transforming
our ideas into reality I hope we can
think critically about the realities
we're working on creating we know we're
not all civil engineers but especially
now the world could use a lot more
building of bridges than it could have
walls so thank you Colombia to my
professors
Thank You Columbia to my professors and
classmates for pushing us not just to be
inventors but to be thoughtful
empathetic and daring enough to invent a
better world and I'm thanking people to
my family for putting up with phone
calls for four years of ongoing midlife
crisis to my acapella group notes and
keys thank you for filling my life with
music most of all thank you to the
leaders of color Columbia's outdoor
orientation program being surrounded by
a group of people they're committed to
sharing their love of Columbia with
incoming first years has been the
biggest of privileges you've been my
family through rain and shine through
Gorp and glitter and your eternal energy
and depth of your commitment to the
people around you won't spire me for
many more a few weeks ago I snuck up on
to the roof of mud sorry Dean voice and
looking at over campus I was struck by
just a small scene spanning only a few
blocks blocks into avenues but in just
four years we made this little
rectangular world filling it with more
memories laughter and friendships than I
ever could have imagined and sure is
bittersweet to leave so goodbye class of
goodbye Columbia and goodbye holographic
weightlifter roar lion's roar hand
Congrats on graduating
and now to present the Columbia
engineering class of 2017 senior gift
I'd like to welcome to the podium
constructive re the senior fund
committee chair Thank You nua before we
announce the results I'd like to extend
our thanks and appreciation to the
members of the 2017 senior fund
committee please stand and now I welcome
Dean boys to the podium for this
presentation on behalf of the senior
committee we proudly present to you the
scroll with the names of every senior
who has participated in her class gifts
a $13,000 624 from student donations
thank you
to my fellow graduates today I thank you
for your amazing generosity and spirit I
hope that you'll remember the wonderful
experiences that you have during your
time at Columbia engineering and remain
involved as alumni it is now my pleasure
to introduce professor Suleiman kijani
senior vice dean of Columbia engineering
and vice provost for teaching and
learning at Columbia University who will
present the Graduate Awards please
welcome Dean Kajaani thank you Kasich
I'm now pleased to present the graduate
student awards to those students who
embody and preserve the ideals and
heritage of the full Foundation School
of Engineering and Applied Science the
Morton be Friedman memorial prize for
excellence is presented this year to
yelena morozova CH vehicle nicholas
yelena received her master's and
doctoral degrees from our department of
electrical engineering where she was
awarded the electrical engineering MS
award of excellence
C she is currently a postdoctoral
associate at Boston University and a
visiting scholar at MIT her thesis
research was awarded the 2015 welcome
innovation fellowship and was featured
in I Triple E spectrum she was named one
of the ten women in networking
communications that you should watch in
2016 Jelena designed the first cellular
networking hands-on lab receiving a
Jinni degree 2013 best educational paper
award and the Jacob Millman prize for
excellence in teaching assistants
congratulations
Elena
[Applause]
the graduate student life leadership
awards are given this year to hungee air
Mullen Donna Lozano and protrusion alum
their participation and involvement at
Columbia have enhanced the spirit of
graduate student life on campus creating
a more purposeful caring and celebrative
community Huang is receiving his PhD in
civil engineering and engineering
mechanics he has served as both a
research assistant and teaching
assistant in various courses one was a
founding member of the Columbia Latin
American student society an active
contributor to the engineering graduate
student council and engineering
achievers in graduate education he's now
a project engineer
Troughton Thomas Petty's Wed linger
applied science practice Prakash has
demonstrated exceptional leadership on
the ingenuity student council where he
has developed and launched professional
development opportunities for fellow
engineering students additionally he
served on the Senate committee for
students with disabilities
tritter she's an aspiring entrepreneur
and he is now a software engineer in the
cloud and enterprise division on
Microsoft please join me in
congratulating who on and pressures
[Applause]
I'm pleased to now introduce Ethan Wong
who was selected by the faculty and her
peers to speak on behalf of graduate
students at class day each one has been
a role model and friend to other
students during her time at Columbia
engineering where she has worked
diligently to complete the Masters of
Science in operations research upon
graduating she will return to China
where she plans to apply her new skills
to Chinese financial markets please help
me welcome to the podium
Ethan Wong thank you thank you Tony
good afternoon you all look great today
I want to thank president Bollinger
importance Tinka journey columbia
engineering the ir department metal
setters and my classmates you all has
made my experience at columbia
unforgettable I didn't expect to be
selected to be the graduate student
speaker
I feel very privileged to be standing
here to share my Columbia story with you
even though we may have different
experiences our emotions are similar the
authority for events the joy from the
more classes in the Stanley's to live in
Columbia today the first time I visited
Columbia was five years ago at that time
I could not imagine it would ever be my
alma mater
however after hard preparation for exams
projects and internships like everyone
sitting here and made it giving up my
job in Beijing and coming to Columbia to
pursue my academic dream the dynamic
nature of financial markets and the
application of quantitative skills have
always appealed to me what I've gained
is so much greater than what I left
behind this is the best choice as
ever made there are so many unique
experiences at Columbia engineering I
enjoy working with talented engineers
like you chatting with friends from all
of the world the cumbia engineer
professors Alex superstars who I could
only meet in textbooks before and now
they encouraged me to express myself but
it is more than engineering here the
cross registration experience with other
schools is so cool and there I was able
to leverage and apply the quantitative
skills I learned from our schools I also
have fond memories of going after class
to the genes which is always open to us
though we can hardly find any available
equipment there Columbia's not only
carried our unique memories but also
offered us confidence to live in a
competitive city like New York I would a
girl who cannot speak English
confidently who knew nothing about the
US financial market and now I've growing
to the person who stands here today who
would in the financial services company
darling with entrepreneur's successfully
and now that we have fun we are ready to
graduate
graduation is another start rather than
an end and we are ready for the
challenges in this new chapter of our
lives the knowledge will learn the
confidence we gain and the skills we of
hard at Columbia engineering enable us
to solve tough problems our humanity is
facing we will all accomplish many great
things in the years ahead
but remember no matter how far we go to
pursue our dream we should often come
back home to Columbia engineering I want
to send clown via a meandering
considered that
Thank You Columbia congratulations on
your graduation class of 2017
[Applause]
next I would like to introduce Rene
testa the Claudia engineering alumni
association president welcome thank you
you fan at this pivotal point in your
careers and in fact in your lives it's a
privilege and a pleasure to be
addressing you I come today as president
of Columbia engineering Alumni
Association to offer congratulate
congratulations and a warm welcome on
behalf of the roughly 35,000 alumni
worldwide who are all members of CEA a
just as you now become it is with much
pride and expectation that we welcome
you to the class of 2017 today you join
a worldwide network of colleagues who
share the rigorous educational
experience you've received here at
Columbia as students the school has
provided you not only with a foundation
for professional opportunities but more
importantly an analytical base and
mindset with which to pursue any
endeavor and in the process you have
made lasting friendships as alumni we in
turn have a responsibility to share
broadly all of the transformative ways
in which Columbia engineering has shaped
us whether through mentoring
volunteering or simply staying in touch
we count on you now to continue the
tradition to help ensure that our school
retains its greatness for the generation
of Columbia Engineers
come I'm in a particularly good position
to tell you that the link to Columbia
engineering is a lifelong one as a
student a graduate a faculty member for
many years and as an act of alumnus I
have experienced that strong linkage
just as I have witnessed it in so many
former students I am certain that you
will always remember your connection to
this hallowed institution and we your
fellow alumni and CEA a are always here
as your support network I urge you all
to keep in touch the active the true
Columbia blue congratulations from
35,000 of us to the class of 2017
[Applause]
each year a number of CEA a awards
recognize outstanding students alumni
and faculty achievements our schools
tradition of excellence is sustained
first and foremost by the caliber of our
students in celebration of your
excellence CEA a has created the
distinguished Student Leadership Award
in honor of Charles Kendall class of
1911 this award is given to two
graduating students one undergraduate
and one graduate who have promoted the
best interests of columbia participated
in a wide array of co-curricular
activities actively contributed to
student alumni affairs and who embody
the traditions of so many past and
present alumni this year's awardees are
two outstanding individuals as the first
female engineer to lead Columbia
Spectator this year's undergraduate
recipient led an organization of over
270 student writers and staff working
tirelessly to keep all members of our
community informed and engaged
with Columbia News through her work as
editor-in-chief at the spec she has also
helped C's alumni stay connected to our
campus here in Morningside Heights
please join me in congratulating this
year's undergraduate recipient Caroline
Shue
[Applause]
this year's graduate recipients have
served as president of Columbia's
National Society of black engineers
chapter look led the Delta Sigma Theta
Sorority and mentor CH fellow Columbia
students through the double Discovery
Center during her time at Columbia she
has been the epitome of selfless student
leadership and dedicated countless hours
in support of the Columbia community I
ask you to join me in congratulating
this year's graduate recipients Deborah
Wahby
[Applause]
in addition to our student recognitions
one of my great pleasures as president
of CAA and as a past faculty member is
to recognize the outstanding faculty of
our school the distinguished faculty
teaching award has been awarded each
year for the past 20 years to Columbia
engineering educators in recognition of
excellence in teaching today based in
part on your course evaluations CEA
honors Julius Chang and John Paisley as
recipients of this year's distinguished
faculty Teaching Award
[Applause]
[Music]
Julius Chang is a lecturer and civil
engineering a colleague where he teaches
graduate and undergraduate courses in
construction engineering and management
dr. Chang is also a professional
associate at HDR a leading consulting
engineering firm his area of interest
being infrastructure asset management
and innovative project delivery methods
John Paisley is assistant professor in
the Department of Electrical Engineering
his interests focus on statistical
statistical machine learning with broad
application to data analysis he also he
is also associated with the data
Sciences Institute here at Columbia
please join me in congratulating these
two faculty members
[Applause]
finally I have the distinct pleasure of
welcoming back to campus our Jubilee
class of 1967 Jubilee graduates our
alumni celebrating their 50th year
reunion and who maintained a lifelong
connection with the school I invite our
Jubilee alumni from the class of 1967 to
please stand and be recognized for this
milestone occasion now I would like to
invite engineering Dean Mary Boyce back
to the podium Thank You Ronnie and
congratulations Columbia engineering
class of 2017 today is really a
magnificent day a special day a day of
joy to celebrate and to reflect upon
your time here at Columbia you have come
to Colombia - Colombia engineering from
across the country and from around the
world you each brought your own unique
self to Colombia your talents your
perspectives your aspirations you have
shared these with one another with our
faculty with Colombia you've each
charted your own path through Colombia
defining your unique Colombia experience
you will eat soon believe in Colombia
enriched by the steep intellectual
community and worldview
you will be graduating with a degree in
engineering and applied science from the
greatest school in the greatest
university in the greatest city of the
world congratulations and you're sharing
this special day with the wonderful
friends you have made here who are
standing with you here today
the friendships and connections you have
made here will last a lifetime you're
forever connected to one another and you
are connected to thousands of people
around the globe a select worldwide
community of people that proudly call
themselves Columbia alumni now you will
be starting the next phase of your
journey you're graduating at a moment in
history when engineering has never been
more central to society more needed to
address the pressing challenges facing
humanity - Lee inspired us with his
words the potential for AI to
revolutionize and positively transform
our lives and lives around the world
this positive transformational impact is
not only enabled by AI but also by
engineering more broadly in fact it's
nearly impossible to think of an area of
life or a field or a discipline where
engineering is not playing a
transformative role today our profession
has enormous opportunities for impact
from addressing climate reducing the
carbon footprints to creating new
avenues for clean air and water
advancing health and wellness from
understanding disease to developing new
diagnostics and therapeutics
enhancing our connectivity to one
another and to the world addressing
physical financial and cybersecurity
harnessing the challenges and the
opportunities presented by data science
and by nanoscience providing new avenues
for greater creativity and joy through
technology many of you are entering
fields that are changing rapidly some
even look different today than when you
started at Columbia this accelerating
pace of change should excite you the
knowledge that you have gained here the
projects you have collaborated on with
fellow students the research you have
pioneered the internships which have
expanded your base the questions you
have debated with your peers and with
faculty the many nights you have spent
working long and hard on problem sets or
studying for exams as cosmos implied
this brings a whole new meaning to the
phrase the city that never sleeps
all of these things have helped shape
you and prepare you as you move into the
future Engineering is now recognized as
a foundational degree that prepares you
for any career for any future and for
the many turns your future will take it
prepares you for lifelong learning for
rapidly adapting to change for
persistence for thoughtful leadership
and for real impact earlier this spring
we unveiled an exciting new vision for
the school one built on our proud
history of discovery innovation and
impact while also looking ahead to the
areas where Columbia engineers have the
ability and the power to make a real
difference in the world to harness our
creativity our talent and our
persistence to bring real impact and
sustainability in health insecurity
income
activity and in creativity we call that
vision Columbia engineering for Humanity
and you can see this embodied in the
stamp imprinted on the inside of your
programs Columbia engineering humanity
reflects our great past our present and
our aspirations for the future it
embodies our frontier education our
research and innovation but also
importantly embodies our people our
students our faculty our alumni you each
embody Columbia engineering for Humanity
you me the faculty all of us together I
want to invite you to think about what
this means to you now and going forward
perhaps you travel to Morocco or Uganda
with engineers Without Borders you
brainstorm with teammates on design
challenges on urban water or sensing for
the city in Rio de Janeiro or address
the Ebola crisis in western Africa or
you thought deeply about a global
problem that technology could impact for
the Columbia venture competition some of
you worked with middle school and high
school students to expose them to the
excitement of science technology
engineering and mathematics some of you
started clubs or organized software and
hardware or maker development courses
and hackathon so that fellow students
could have a more creative hands-on
learning experience here at Columbia
some of you worked on biomedical product
development to invent effective forms of
diagnosis and treatment or use machine
learning to find new angles for thinking
about age-old problems and questions
from social justice to financial
security to robust electric grids or you
invented new ways to harness life or
design tips for revolutionising
computation and autonomous systems or
drones for cleaners and
and reliable agricultural systems
algorithms for animation you've
researched how roads bridges and tunnels
can be more resilient and more
sustainable and how cities could be made
smarter and more enjoyable for those who
live in them our amazing faculty and you
our amazing student body embody Columbia
engineering Fremont for unity every day
our vision and aspiration captures Chi
Foods advice to bring your empathy your
humanity and your heart together with
your engineering talent to impact our
world and we cannot wait to see how you
build this vision in the next phase and
your next 10 years you entered Columbia
as some of the best and brightest
students you have an appreciation for
equations so I can I'm sure that you can
see how Columbia has given you an
incredible amplification factor there
are many pieces to this equation your
first class education your supportive
peers who helped them challenged you
teachers who encouraged and inspired you
and let's not forget our incredible
location the world capital New York City
this columbia education has enabled you
to discover more about yourself develop
more in every dimension and expand your
perspective and your horizon I speak for
the entire faculty and staff when I say
that you have inspired us we have been
so inspired to see what you accomplished
and what you will accomplish going
forward whether it was in the lab or
outside the lab in the classroom outside
the classroom and what you will do in
the future
most important you met and connected
with an incredibly talent and diverse
set of peers from across the nation and
around the world
these are your friends your allies your
midnight Network and your second family
your Colombia family to take a moment to
look around to thank one another take a
moment and congratulate each other you
have also been supported along this path
by your family and your friends many of
them are here to celebrate this special
day with you so take a moment look to
your left and look to your right this is
really amazing thank your family thank
your friends for all they've done for
you
so if you prepare to leave Columbia my
message to you is that your Columbia
education is about so much more than
what you've learned in the classroom and
in the laboratory it has prepared you
for a bold future your path may be
engineering and technology focus in
industry or through an entrepreneurial
startup or it may be in academia law
finance medicine business or even in the
fine arts whatever your path your
engineering and applied science
foundation and your broader Columbia
experience will inform everything you do
we hope you will have the courage to
choose the direction that you care most
deeply about to change direction when
needed and to bring your signature to
everything you do you will always look
back proudly on this day the day you
became part of the Columbia legacy so to
the C's class of 2017 I join with your
family your friends our faculty and
staff to acknowledge your talent your
creativity your achievements and your
perseverance that you have brought with
you here today on the South Lawn
congratulations class of 2017
and now as we make a transition from
students to alumni I'm pleased to
present on your behalf to award to honor
exceptional faculty members who
represent the highest standards of
excellence in leadership in areas that
have directly impacted the lives of
students here at Columbia the first
award is the Edward and Carol Kim award
for faculty involvement in appreciation
for their son Brian's experience here as
a student the Kim's created this award
to honor a faculty member who is not
only an excellent teacher but also shows
a special and a personal commitment to
students in recognition of her of her
role as mentor advisor and caring
professor I'm pleased to present a Kim
Award for faculty involvement to KT bar
Max's eerie the Philips Electronics
professor of Applied Physics and Applied
Mathematics those
those of you who have had classes with
Professor Barr Mac know that she's an
outstanding scholar who's teaching is
praised by her students her mentorship
and advising have helped countless
students secure internships and research
positions and most of all gain a
lifelong appreciation for the hidden
nature of materials they have all
benefited greatly from her dedication
and her personal attention
she has also led the planning and
establishment of the transmission
electron microscope facility which is
critical for advanced material science
and nanotechnology research across
Columbia so congratulations
Katey
[Applause]
the second award was created by
engineering alums and university trustee
Armand Evanescence and his wife Jeanette
to honor a faculty member whose actions
encouraged men and women from diverse
backgrounds become part of the academic
community of engineering education this
year I'm proud to present the Jeanette
and Armand Evanescence diversity award
to the lens fest
Earth Institute associate professor of
climate change
Alisa Park professor professor Park
professor Park has been a tireless
champion for her students and a role
model for innovative research and
mentoring of PhD students and junior
researchers her research in carbon
capture utilization and storage has
broad impact in practice and research
students mentored by her have gained
real opportunities to translate ideas
into impact one graduate student is even
traveling to Beijing to work with
Professor Park through our global center
as part of a new startup called green or
which is dedicated to sustainable energy
solutions this is a wonderful
achievement that could not have happened
without Alisa support congratulations
Alisa
[Applause]
and now it is my great pleasure to
introduce the 19th president of Columbia
University President Lee Bollinger
[Applause]
president Bollinger is a preeminent
legal scholar and a stalwart defender of
the First Amendment and free speech
during his 15-year presidency he has
been instrumental in making Columbia
University one of the premier research
universities in the world and initiating
its most ambitious expansion in more
than a century with Manhattanville being
perhaps its most visible component with
the recent announcement of the Columbia
commitment he has set a clear path
forward for the university to work
together to address the challenges
facing our world today he continues to
be a strong supporter of the engineering
school and our belief that engineering
should be at the service of humanity he
has increased cumbias global presence
and reach and now with columbia world
projects has launched a new initiative
that harnesses the collective talents of
our faculty and of our students to find
practical solutions to real world
problems and bring columbia to a new
level of impact please join me in
welcoming President Lee Bollinger
[Applause]
thank you very much Mary I want to
extend my warmest congratulations to you
the class of 2017 and also to the
parents and families and friends I also
want to thank I Fuli for his wonderful
talk like you I was touched in hearing
that he had his first date here and
married his wife which proves once again
my view that Colombia is really a dating
service masquerading as an institution
of higher education I want to be very
brief I will have the opportunity to
speak to you on Wednesday and I don't
want to over extend my welcome there are
really just two things that I want and
and need to say to you the first is
about your field engineering technology
it is becoming increasingly clear to
everyone and this is something you have
known actually for a long time that
advances in these areas of knowledge are
transforming the world whether it's the
economy the infrastructure of nations
human health or the ways in which we
access knowledge and communicate
virtually every part of life is not just
affected but in so many ways determined
by what we have learned and can now do
with engineering and technology but the
upshot of that fact is not only that we
need to recognize their importance but
also that we need to consider always
what human purposes what ends of life
are being served by this knowledge and
so I urge you to consider always the
moral social and political implications
of what we do with engineering and tech
ecology this is an easy recommendation I
know but it is very hard to do in my own
field of the Constitution I've seen the
courts and the Supreme Court struggle
over the decades with how to incorporate
new technologies of corporate
communication radio TV cable the
Internet and I've seen new technologies
of communications struggle to how to
incorporate the ethos of the values of
freedom of speech and press this brings
me to my second point your school it
gives me enormous pleasure and pride to
see how the School of Engineering and
Applied Sciences is flourishing under
the wonderful leadership of Dean Mary
boyce and the faculty sees has reached
new heights of academic excellence what
truly distinguishes C's of course and
your education in it is its integration
into the life of the mind and in a
liberal arts tradition this is a
wonderful gift to the school to the
University and to the broader world and
to you its graduates I hope you always
treasure this unique and very special
character of seize and take appropriate
pride in it congratulations I look
forward to seeing you on Wednesday thank
[Applause]
so at this time all undergraduate degree
recipients and candidates will be
invited to the stage for recognition
before we start that I want to say a few
words about this undergraduate class of
2017 this is the first undergraduate
class that I have followed each of you
from your entering to completion for
those who entered as first years I
entered as the first year and so I just
thought I should wanted to acknowledge
that because we're all in this together
and it's really a pleasure to see you
graduates today
so advisors from the James age and
Christine Turk Derek Center for student
advising and from the undergraduate
student affairs and global programs who
have supported these students throughout
their Columbia careers have the honor of
reading each graduates name as they
process across the stage I ask that you
please refrain from applause family
friends until all members of the class
has returned to their seats and so we
begin
community
but they're in
cosmos our first thing Noah Jacobs we
been cough Liesl a cosmos a bindi machi
biernat ski Sarah young Mina Kim
so here Jaggi Christina andreyeva Tyler
Cowen test
Elizabeth keys sir sanski Lisette
Delgadillo Sydney James Perkins
Nia John Kasich Kumar Tiwari
Carolyn q Anthony Johnson cero Richard K
for guar John Cote Kochi Brendan Ross
Stuart prayer Nicoli Elaine McDonald
jibin League grab hide Hillen Sarah
Nicole Gouveia Mitchell Ellis Bustillo
Christopher s on RML andreas Pena
Alcantara Mert evarin element Joshua
Wilkinson Jews jessica van de bon the
Hien toss meme Sarkar amanda marie
jimenez uma way Zane
Zenon Zim brain Jonathan Barrios ich on
guru
Stephanie yang guang Nina Singh
Sabharwal
Samuel Weinreb Priya Sharma med berry
Nina
Alexandra moiseevich Erica why McManus
Roberta lock Alexandra Anna's been and
kwan-yuen Fiona Mary Rowan
Sneha stillwall Eunice
Amitha Coker Sandra Schaefer Michael
Allen Bergson Sean Collins Mobilio Erika
Aileen yi Emily Wang mang Edmund G air
cho Macklin brand wine Shawn in a way
Alec James on a chow ski Meredith page
Polly
Samantha whiner Matthew pickle Ella
Thibault Baptiste nuke fur Stanley
George Brown the third Rashid Al Judah
you dear luck Hall Evan her to Feld
honor odd ready
Chinna Polly Donna Slavs Carol
Puccini the third sherry Q Michelle yi
soo new shoe yolu Olivia Samia Caballero
ciao you Lu Chen Zhong Kritika Suri
Urbano San Ramon zon where Faraj Juliana
Kim Lin hao Zhang Jian Xiu Fong Chi Quan
Edwin Xiang ji Hong Kong Shao Qi Liu Q
Sal Keon she's young
Emanuel Jana Dara quaint rope Alexander
Franklin Botti Kyle
Austin Bauer Jessica chef Rebecca speken
Bach on a he Bradley Ray beaks ma Benjy
Griffin Adelaide Graham young Jefferson
Hancock Yasmine Adriana mullah Carillo
max well done Oliver Marcus grew Turek
William Eugene McKee Ricardo Andres
frites crease Anna master Koba Manuel
Chopard Jesse William matzo Alison
Spencer
Madeline Lindy Carolyn Duggan Trimble
Jake a beach ball Adam Nogueira Haddad
Alicia creeper Coppedge a manual command
aki Kiara vallini
and read David Sato Mohammed Jafar
Daniel Pratt Matt amino mature Luigi
Givaudan marker for the siwash Darren
Shan Shan Tigers whoa Lena wrong
Johann on surah 18 rahman alexandra
maria della Santina and the Katherine
Libby Adam Paul Cho Minsky who are Zhang
Jun forms you
Colton John during Jenna 410 live
between applauded Courtney Elizabeth
Beckwith
Oliver Caspar conquer Lennon when Sophia
Dolan Ryan Patrick Zimmerman June who
Yoon Brandon action box I Kevin Cheng
John Magruder Anthony Lee money
Annelle ready Matt Kovac Steven ho
Samuel measurer Cecilia Seema's daruka
agulu met Matata South pel Angelica
Sonakshi both Roy uses chiffon Alexandra
cantos Diego Delgado Frankie bada
Michael Ethan Burke with Danielle Rojas
Marissa Ojeda
Lara is Minh llaman Turkmen Yigit Ilya
Cecily
Kylie Yong Seon Yong Seon Joe Christie
Chi Yong ho
Dada Yan song Shinshu REO Shin Ji Yong
Rooijen Akash ready kancharla Larry
Anthony CEO ish and colori Harris Nair
Calvin Thien ly Hawai Ian Thomas are
very keen on Eugene Sumner Alvey
Nathan Mendel Werner Jessica Ruth David
Jackson boffin nadim Amin Mossad Alicia
Musa ru-tang crystal Hanna Tanaka Kevin
yay
Jane's with Carrie Susan cook a shriek
Vitali
Robert Gregory Frierson Alison way Cheng
Cheng Laura Casey Karen Dan ma che
Chon Chon Wang Ling Xiang yang Jin Xuan
Xuan
Tina do okorafor Stephanie Borg of V cos
Arun Jacqueline Lee a perigee Sumitra
Karolina Lazaro recent Tanya Paredes
Juarez Taylor Alexandra Thompson kya
karoon Hong Dexter Eugene calendar the
third Kelsey nanan Dean DP Patel Thomas
Scott Rasmussen jonathan albert cohen
daniel Isaac Gonzales David Alexander
Sanchez
Alan Michael andreas Riddler Kevin 115
aha new Ian face joonyoung you Kathleen
Gao fan William you Alexandra Sascha
loureno Joshua Alexander Goldman risky
air today de ji hyung Jun Zoe Vegas
David Emery Brown a cool aurora Jesse
Jones and Martha Ricardo Moritz Martinez
Kyle Kevin mosquito Bible Chavez Leela
Hosea Carla smarter sharper Coolidge
Victoria Fernandez grander
Matthew Saji Ana's Haley Catherine Cadiz
Christina Michaels Jamar ke liye bird
then ray Leo Martine Luis Perez come on
Jacob Michael Greenberg ojou Sudarshan
satay Eli Zachary episode Varun head
today
Alexander Ashton Brown min Healey naam G
Park Andrew sangwon Kim you do Jing
Marina who gay young Lee Daniel
Moskowitz
David Verdi anituchi Nick Harry Monroe
Jian and
Kian Lee Jung soo Yun Hwa Jung Joo Nam
Dae young Jeff Peterson wooly Zachary
home
Victoria Ming Lee cybertor oppresses
Sara Lee Jung Justin avendao vijaya
pool Varro's Mooney Yong Chi - Veronica
Genevieve campaign Gabrielle Ashley
Taylor Mitchell Alan Gouzenko kevin chen
ben yehuda Israelis Jorge Antonio or Bay
Jonathan Jerome pod on Kevin police
buckaroo
Rajeev Sam barrage a Bernard oil
Henry Jacob syllabus
Nicodemus Damian skarphol Jamie Rowland
Alexander whole Alyssa possession he
wins young Levi's Oliver Rafi's on max
meteo Lee Alshaya alum Hansie
Colette Mary McCulloch Maria Kaitlyn
Torres Shelton Susan Lou Williams estaba
Rodriguez Shane shows Jocelyn ano my
Munna Hussein Carlos G Morales
Patricia Javier Torres Devin Chad effigy
he was a virtue Justin so young lee
ji-won park
Julian Manuel real jr. Douglas total San
Riata LeDoux daehwa Trayvon Oh Colleen
meeple cateura M devil as these are
Addie soakin strong June day Haroon
Muhammad me on Tiffany a Gannett West
Widow facial EK t DK
area Millis Perkins
Ashley Murrieta Belle Tyler Alexander
Allen Jenny Lee Cory and Ray Petra's
Kareem Carson Stanley Stanley through
Feldman a decathlon Schwarzschild Jake
Weissman keep Hannah Brady Samuel
adenine Odin Martina are Chong Chong a
Kabam
Tiana Haile Stewart Charbonneau darton
Kathy Amira nebith
Jonathan Kanerva Lauren Rae da hood
brian Hisashi Louie
Christopher Chang and release own Gary
Emlyn Andrew 10 MOOC on Subramanian
Uncas MSHA who some shakir Abdul Kathy
un hang loose
Christopher lamb Stephen Coe uncial
Joshi Sebastian Jose Ortega
Robert could Kowski Frederick Nicholas
Anaya Priscilla you being Wang PU she
Bishnoi florian shabana's David poo
Joshua nuez Steven EULA Hannon Minh
Truong joshing sue Julian Sean Edwards
Benjamin learner Raphael Gotti takasu
ignacio Torah David Philip Alper
Anthony Kim John Robert Hazell man the
fourth Shri Hari Devaraj Bryan you
ratchet Mohan
Allen go Jacob grass
Abby Chatterjee Daniel Hong Ilan
Buckwald amrita Musa poot La Nina Kumar
Rebecca grace Carloni Laura Elaine
Warner Alice Wong Maya Patel Georgiana
young men deal in Cathy Wong Helen
Elizabeth Letty Farrah Mehdi Simpson
Wang Ying Li Harsha Vemuri Ricky a beach
on Donnie
II do raw Raya Midori puddle ker
Miyoung Mahajan Soren Campbell Mort vet
Harrison Michael dittmeyer Jake young
Park
Ludovico Yaga bisetti Emily Elizabeth
la Battaglia Ming Jing Joe Lindsey
Nicole with Cameron Marie satin Edwin
Vargas Tejas David Zhang Hao the quasi
Douglas boondi Taylor Charles Michael
Visconti jr. Sean Hempstead McDonald
Joseph George will be the third Clayton
Garmin Baumgart
will Samuel Clifford fired a Neville
mince on Kim
soon he Hahn
juhi Kong guy young Kim Andrew south
Katy young Mary Catherine Montgomery
Alexander Wang Christopher Lauren Harris
Gaugin Jonas Mehta Faria Naughton fella
kakarrot Seoul Raj Josie
Justin Harrison mom Kevin - Shaw Simon
Frances Fox Paulo
Eduardo Lima Parente James Delgado rishi
Tandon Brandon Vincent Massey Oh Julian
Marcelo radicchio
badal Jaime Nino de Guzman Luis Pena
John Robert bender are ya ku
Timothy leaming Goodwin James Walter
page Kevin CK Wang Jonathan Matthew Yi
Ann Marie Chen Ryoko no anthony James
Holley
Cynthia Lynn Calif Jeremy Lin Derrick
Francis Neto
hye-young Kim Peter Jacob luening procs
Dexter dee Antonio Christopher J kunkel
Benjamin Daniel mocking her William
Church Vincent Zhao nicholas john premia
no crystal Mejia Marquez Adil tyub Walid
Raman hey Chong Kim
Jeong Joon Kim Oliver why Whillans
pile Rana Stanley
Spencer Sandoval
[Applause]
okay so let's give a round of applause
to our graduating bachelor science
degrees class of 2017
at this time all graduate degree
recipients and candidates will be
invited to the stage for recognition
staff leaders who supported new students
throughout their Columbia careers have
the honor of reading each graduates name
as they persist across the stage I ask
you again to refrain from applause until
all members of the class have been
called
thank you and so we begin again you find
Wang I swear I or Chevron fossil-bearing
hurry to run me rack up your break mtis
Chauhan critique ashabi Sava min Chi
Hwan Darrell Chua
you named Kong Ching Jake now shooting
Tong Zhong Yi team Chia she held on
Eugene phones London Seong Joon wave Leo
Yui she'll tell you she's lying on Ginny
and Joe given chin the bill Khan heat
all bombing Yasin Joo Ashwin preached on
Ian clown Luke cow tech zero harbour
yong-soo Michael Sweeney Gregory
Salamone a Lumumba GTA ignacio's are
eager in fun full way ye shall sing Tony
Hsieh Yuen Li ye mean Wong Lee hojun you
we in you Jia you a swap Shi Xiao Lu Bo
and Luke you and us you jinglun Qi Han
Xiao Xiao Liang Lin Ian Johnson V Xiao
Zhu Naja Jose Daniel Ramirez Soto Juan
Martin virgeen Oh Diego Yahoo Carlos
Espino Garcia Eugene Sun she way slim
high end Carol you young song Jackie
young you've won shin Liu ye chow yeah
SHINee Jong James Yoo si Jin jung-min
dantian Taniya Sally
Reverend Raghu Shetty an instrument sing
dick Sheldon Bari garage today car Bohol
Jane are you Jane Sahil Josh chef Watson
Fiat dangers Jew
Ching men Xiang Ning ma Zi Han Liu
Arriaga la rioja is Melina Nicole people
started trusting Nicole Mitra Oscar
Audra as she's manda Jai Sharma arun
sharma are fun when you when Jung Joos
England Nicholas got home vadas vodka
teeth Federico loca Kelly didn't kill
Karen
Jakob Cara lucha Laura Italo Quinto
Bernard Tony
Michael Monroe hungry yang Zhong Shan
Xue Zhang Wang Zhi Hao joke
highway wu yunzhao
she all Shinhan raehwan i'm cheese young
Nicholas
Carlini proudly in Joshua Cara casaba
she chillin Ethan Wong Sharaku pika
Michelle cope we take David ding Sammy
Ovilus II willow Shing lon al erasers
are Yong Chi Y Mach retro Ventura Gary
anonymous because Mohandas Jing Jie ma
Wan Chi su
tell yang bong-soon shi Yan nonsense
Sarina Liu Michelle Levine garage rock
cos my Saira I build my he'd lose our
airman scheffers up in Turkish Elias
Hussein Shruti Pandey
Gianna Craig or Leo Anna Dorothy Ann
Arbor Jean
Abhishek - shy when true IRAs on race I
you can Julie Chen John Chung Chien Qing
G mu nan Jiang Yan Wei Jing Zhi Li la si
Yoon ji Zhongshan you want some Jia leg
Jung Hwan beam shoe you lost you Ming
Cheng Han Tian Shan Wong who Liu ke Zi
Luo Jung barley using Chung chyron yay
you fake site Jia Ming Chen Jason Wang
Yi love Xiao Qing Cheng Zhi way Wang
shame yang jujin Salina gingy sia
general Xiao Li south on Chao
yi ting li Yan Lang who pass the corn
sana Python Yellin gua Yi Jung soo-jung
Wong Jing Jing lu p jung-hwa wong hau
Wang told here
Yan Cheng Han Ling yi Liu Xiao Han Jung
use 110c girl Winfield's Jason soy Ron
longshan Neha Gupta oka galava bhakti
Shaheen
Sotiris elo bro John bitch Wan Chi papa
Louie
Kathryn Kuhlman choice Michael add one
Othman taluk mejor add Vernon coach
wanna share Adam Saran suya Ronon Rakesh
yo ligado Sri Hari
sridhar Nathaniel Jones sutiya Chen Ryan
Joseph Ming Yue Li Alex Gandhi Jason
moody Mirim Klein the mengjie fan Jang
Anthony garrison Lu Wei Jung Yong Yong
Jia Jia Jiang Yan Xiu Tai Yi soo Yong
Yong
han joon-soo ting Tong you Lu Wu Lin
Lang Lee shin yeah how can I choose
Shetty scenario on Yetta job guru
nothing umma ready Jason Xu Hong chuan
Chen Candice Ungaro
Olga Pavlenko madhavendra Maria she won
goo hyung another and Anthony action
our tongue neuen Kim sook Sharma
amber go Avinash ramekin Munoz moussala
awesome money our Karuna room Vika
Bansal Gabriel Mallick poor pairen
Barossa Purita food Apsara
Rajesh Devon she via Prakash
shrivastav's Rohan Kulkarni
Vinay GABA Arushi aura
Suhana single Negev novice Yong Yong Li
Anissa
Kubelik Lauren B Y Choi young Jin Kim
Chen Chen Qi Xiu Shi an Mei Chen Yan ji
soo Park chopping liao
dan han ji figure Henry gua Rohit dan
pulley
Yuto you American emini exam Alphaeus
Gary Eichmann Qian Liang Alexander
swaggin Sunni Fung Manuel Rita
mu Jin Kim Cuong um one is some shock
upon Tom you a young gazelle the joy one
monkey chow Lika fella
I want e WA er Carlota Perez ah
Fabiana Rodriguez Andres Diaz Niall wife
Christina shoes Victor Alva supporter
jin chen yi ling tong young the long one
during - genuine full weight champion
Lena one Mamie Pascal
- gay Arush champion wave hung down ten
can yahooey siddhis atrium Monica
Kunta Sania Aras won shin eaten beyond
lee Picchu Marika narubu
Nilesh Chowdhury harsh branded Tiwari
Samak or Tamarama nikhil handle our and
dica - smooth scanned Mishra
Kanika Milani Mohammed sorry boo
Jacob dosey doe Raymond who Mary miser
Jordan chosen Shang Lin Wu you tensor
Dre scoop Alan McNamee William Joseph
McConnell Janelle innocent
Michael Crafton geophone Jessica Ellis
Emily here for Ellen O'Brien Chandan can
google to Haas gundo Rao
Aditya back three siren Jacob
Jin Xiu Ning Jing you waiting Joshu
Liang talika haha
Sam pal Rita pooja Kumar and he Jane
Regina Sha Sha Tsui Saran en Kailash
suehila mati
Trini Silvana Vani Alam croutha Moe
Gilley rotten wife
Shivan Chaudhary
Sukanya Sarika maher Moneta men her son
her a Madhu
chun qiang monkey one Xu yang Xiao ma
filter boom Alisha
Kalfas Rohan rain shreya Kumar
Nikita natera Xiao Qiang ma trailing
Zhang Qing Feng hua Zhu Chen Hao Liu hi
you and Tao Zi Tong Zhong yang hyun
joong serve on Kumar Chandra stockin
Rashad ha Achilles Ramakrishna Michael
Begum Akshay Kumar rocky shop
shin-chan mean see Yogesh with Bosna
Jorge Guerrero marine pratik Jade daya a
beachside revita the spongy after Tamiya
boot Ali emits danda Richard Sherman
Tarun pancha boonie Strabane Kumar ganda
this wanna our deep knowledge we back to
my poly project mu PD yes once Puma
Ramesh Babu
Shashank Murthy Harish Karthikeyan Sonny
aguar so Roop Kumar priyank lot wall
Harish
Mahajan Priya Kishore Aakansha
kundo wall Somali Bapat posh Parikh
Monica Tsonga a la carte serve on irani
lunch in in how hung Jeffrey house
Andrew grant Bob minutes mimics Daniel
cost Steffensen Joshua Daniel staff in a
digit suprem Fernanda cabanas ya seen
you
un you seen attention Kenny shall the 10
down she you leo
cha ching tong Jin Mei Chao Jintao Joo
Yeo Joo Jang Yoon Jin Chen you soon ciao
Yosh in 1 john g li Christina poppin de
metrio Talia's Cerato chica
Elizabeth Joseph Fatima osburgh Rosita
Morelli davara a better Billy Antonio
Prado Chong Xue Zhang Alejandro Sal GL
kookier Bradley Speas Rachel gosh
Enrique lay low till Alera Andrade
Marek sobota sang mija Genesis and xerus
Chavez yi xin low Jeremy on Yankee Lee
crystal on Geoffrey K Rolla bear tour
barracks tour
excuse me helgi Inga mooned arson
porque Montano chen xiu how when pond
gilben delay giorgos Matty cos Alison
Benito Francisco or sale Robert Faust
Liang Shang je Gangji Eden gah Margaret
belong
Caitlyn Mars ji min Lee you Shen side
Sahara loom may Yun Jie Karen ha d Jin
how fan Harry sue Liam thou none
- nu Chen kun Jean hole in shankin Lin
carry new austin ck srinivasan Perry
bar Sharma Karthik Narasimhan young
DRA hoooo Chang Leo care Ying Lee ray Lu
Ray J Chang Jing Chou GU Li Wang Wang
song go
how long Lu Dai Lin Chen Yong Yong Qi
nan Wan Shi Zhang Wang Ming Jing Jun you
won garage get a Yuki Miura su Qing Xiao
Yu Jiang
Ronan sue cen you a Leo ja Jan maan
Ching Wan vag Viet dough Rohith Karuna
Kavya Prem Kumar Gerard convento joseph
Baker
Juan Pablo column er a bougie Roy a
lancret Johari Horace chitin mahir
Pillai Debashish Sanyal devvra more some
deep day Ranjit Kumar sang muga
Vishwanath an Aadhaar smoothie
Abhinav a upon Marshall Van Loon
Rashidah Nayeem tusita Watts zing Zang
zong Robert new house Chen Jiang Lin ow
who shines through time seeing you
Jean vs Silvio Santos Anubhava Garvie
shoe Patrick Chau Rican mother Sultan
Inari took Helen Wong
shall we found young son trans done Yan
Xiang Yu Jin Jin to catch you can see
any young shame Chi Irish massage
that remove Agrabah Karen Kirara shreya
quantum shriek our Quattro sharat
chandra advise r-rajim
zg u n you qingxue sang min Hyo Shin
Arjun joka koku edgy bertocchi Brian
Hargitay partha Axl Buckley chubby
Nikita Philip OH Sharona che Irina
plankton alexandre rodrigues Sergio
Sanchez reshubs shredder karate on
Ashland Karthik s rah-rah garage on
Tracy you Jessie Gong fires ah kapre
Corrine cuckoo Muhammad Rajeev quail ax
ooh mamacita Shriram mu Johar on dois
mill maka
Christopher Perkins I mean the doom
Guido giardini Jaime Andre Scott Iike
your do
amia Amano I'm Minnie well in a
melodious Henry beggin kill Ian
Rutherford Thomas do tray
Ramiro's nuva michael treat rajan
Bhargav regiment above Marge Oh Jonathan
balloon Wesley brooming shreya
Shrivastava David Watkins Brianna
Puentes Zachary Ellen bogan Leah pecker
Derrick novo moon sharee gangwar Gideon
Mendel touchin Preet Kaur Stephanie
Berger
Manu got home you Jin Shan Xing Tian
Ocean and Vince Co Bernardo mafia Cano
Laura Ripley Shi Jin shall not want
k you live Kevin ha Jeffrey gum lick
rafael Pelle Nancy che Rach on che
Andrew Pitts Joanie Michi Congress young
win waste son
Union Wang Jian Li ke jingzhong Gregory
Khmer pilot Chuck sighs large Patrick
roller
be a crush on be JD Rajendra Tony
t-mac - Raksha Simona and their halal
Raji record Manju Zhang
or we could guard Tracy brown glare
Kenya Michaels shun Aziz Qatari shaker
Bhandari Troy
Hodges Kareem Abdullah Alexandra stay
tuned
Andrew Bauer Kevin Jeong peers is for
Christopher
Boulder then yell Strummer Matthew Malik
James Young can chew Vincent Lee auger
ELISA the net Klieman Levitt or Leo Toro
Irwin company on Teresa
sandy Ford Jessica ciao
Michelle Roddy Pratyush nalem
Victor Zini Vincent our tube guillaume
de l'ombre coat on
Renate no Marie shield
Jin Han Lee Shao Williams soy Kody
Hiroshima jin-kun Chan Wallace Joe Curt
young Ito liu yaohua xu qing fan Li Wei
Japan hongou Jin Jing Zhang fantasy Chen
Yong Chi Xiao CAI Julie Chen Daniel
Belgard
Austin Hoppe Chan Khong Guan Yu hon Wong
Jing Jing qu Eugenia kada-chan Whateley
Solberg Dennis Benjamin Stein alekhya
Monica Polly Mamadou Baku a lil roni
Nathan Fabiana
Vasily karate no offer bra the Han Tao
Karen rotten Annie
Deborah Ola Wahby
Deborah Kadam Lauren Butler
Christopher joy seeing whoo telly one
cow you done when Chaitanya Rastogi
Audrey ali-a David's house
Mustafa moba sure Mirai Park Yuchun soo
Medini Anna Valhalla Genevieve
Brown gen Wu poor accrete Leo pramana 2v
[Applause]
chatterin de Silva
Maxim stoner T wolf
Paul stable Jon Chu Chu
hi Shing li e taifeng inbound
Sebastian Simic
Jill German Baeza below to blue
Haroun OspA here AJ air took Kevin nerve
Gelinas i canola one guillermo Logano
Gonzalo muoz Antoine this year
whoo so let's give that round of
applause to our class of 2017
engineering project everyone where we've
made it and we are now going to
celebrate with the cliffhangers and
let's welcome them to the stage they're
going to do a performance of stand
Columbia followed by roar lion roar is
in the book is in the book is it in the
book and the lyrics are in the book
Mother's Day on rocky ground and
horrified by lice Aparna is my rig and
we feel like towards my children oh yeah
ha ha ha wonderful people mourn my
anonymity the day made the name me
rattle Colombia now a day we can play
fighting games again there's a lion
fortified while the Mana Party side all
the losers and white to this tree
and make the Ecuador Colombia Gaza mill
earning forever
on the water on the my central roar
thank you thank you
let's give them one more round come on
so so our celebrations continue this
week so don't forget about Wednesday and
commencement you'll have some wonderful
red hammers and I want you to show your
Columbia engineering straight on
Wednesday
also on Wednesday evening following
commencement and that evening
the Empire State Building will be
illuminated in Columbia blue as a
special tribute to our new graduates so
look out for that it is it is as I say
an Instagram will salute to alma mater
and you can share it with the hashtag
sees the world 2017 s das sees the world
come on now now as we bring this
ceremony to close and you continue your
celebrations we're going to process down
and then everyone can process out so
again thank you everyone for this
magnificent day and congratulations
class of 2017 Oh congratulations
[Applause]